hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play Kuro Oni
now I'm sorry about the delay in this
there were some problems that I ran into
as I was trying to get through the game
so I spoke with that creator of the game
from I don't care games and he been very
very kind and and worked through the
problems and he actually patched it up
to version 1.2 so hopefully all the
problems will be sorted out I have to
start from the beginning but I know what
to do ergo it won't be so bad so here we
go I know that I need to first get the
key from the library and then wait was
there was something behind that painting
right nope it was the other paint was in
this room yeah get the envelope from
here empty envelope nothing on there
okay we should be good
there was nothing in this room right
absolutely nothing okay
nothing in that room and then I can go
straight to the library and I can also
open up that okay and in the library
there was some don't remember what but
that was some something oh no hey wait
no wait
oh no yeah umm yeah the lever the lever
the lever that I have no idea what it
does because it doesn't seem that the
lever actually did anything before but
it was probably just for something that
I haven't gotten to yet so anyway we're
gonna go
let me save just in case cuz you never
know when a monster's gonna come out and
eat your face off okay so umm there was
a key yeah there was a key there but I'm
gonna save that until later just in case
it decides to spawn a monster right on
top of me because that's what it did
last time okay but the lever and there
it seemed to go down and I still can't
do anything with it maybe click drag no
no okay that doesn't do anything this
door here is still locked and it's still
really really really quiet for some
strange reason okay so who I saw like a
little flash of the outside level okay
so down here there is the keypad and
there was something else in the other
room not sure okay still locked
locked still locked still locked still
locked still oh oh yeah the sticks okay
the wood and there's nothing here I have
a feeling that this envelope like hold
it up to a light or something and it'll
probably show the code but there's
nothing at the moment so there's got to
be something else there is that key that
I did not find where it went it went it
was the first floor key ergo it must be
something on the main floor I hate this
hallway why this would have to be so
long and dark the guy the maker of the
game said that he added something
special for me and I don't know what it
was but I have a bad feeling about it
okay so before I take this key I'm going
to get this is nothing yet nothing yet
nothing yet nothing yet nothing yet
nothing yet
okay I went that way so let me go this
way first that way he went kind of
nowhere
ah what's all this then lock door
special surprise maybe anyone is anyone
here is anyone gonna jump out of me and
eat my face ooh hello okay uh wait wait
there's nothing in here there's nothing
in here crap to do the death trap
if that monster was chasing me would it
kill me easily oh hello
oh we got here but I've got here aha
whoo hello nap what's that I don't know
okay a fireplace I have wood yeah how do
i light it there's got to be something
here uh nope no hang on um I don't see
anything then again it's kind of dark up
here alright there's got to be like a
lighter or something or some fuel that I
got a light the fire and then I burn the
envelope oh that's got to be it that's
got to be it okay I burned the envelope
and I go see up here locked haha
oh that's out that oh that's not the
change music that's iam it's just a
random music that pops up every once in
a while alright so I put the wood there
I gotta go somewhere else there's gotta
be something else that I'm missing here
the bottom door is on the first floor
this door
that doors locked I don't think the
store yeah this doors locked too it's
gotta be something that I'm missing
those doors or there's gotta be
something to do with these doors and
those doors but these don't even give a
clunking sound yeah one second I know I
can get this eventually now it's still
locked I mean was there anything in this
room they don't think there was anything
in there from was there something hidden
I don't know cuz the other side the
other side was just a small room there
was nothing there oh wait no I fell oh
okay
Oh does that mean yeah this leads yeah
this is totally different hang on what's
it huh
was this matches they look like matches
come on give it giving it matches yes I
can light the thing on fire now Hot
Diggity I'm doing her I'm doing her whoa
hello hello hi little guys you reminded
me of that logo from that company I
think it was never soft yellow thick
yeah well it looks like there's an
eyeball missing so maybe I got a god
they're looking at me hi hi friends
hello everyone
yeah shut up okay if I ever want that
music to stop I can just say that it'll
go away all right dark hallway lovely
love it love it
anything on the ground here anything I
see something shiny okay no all right
doors ah okay ah that makes a lot more
sense okay so that fell down I loop back
around man this house this house is
messed up man
this house is beyond messed up I do not
like this place okay so so far so much
no monster so that I'm pretty happy
about well I thought I saw something I
was just glinting off the wall sorry
everything's shiny here it's just
nothing's happening and it's really
quiet and I'm creeped out okay so I put
the letter in oh no I burn ah ah what
the hell God Jesus Christ get out of
here
ah come on man oh hey I got a code hello
okay so I just got to get away from you
geez look at you
hi buddy hey there friend oh ha how's it
going how you doing good good I'm gonna
go this way now give me excuse me pardon
me running away okay uh-huh
I guess he's gone now all right good
good good good good good good good good
good good good good good good good good
good good good okay I got cold I could
put I can go down to the basement and uh
let me save I can go down to the
basement and I can finally get through
that keypad whatever that does I don't
um it's not a lot of confirmation on
when things clicker or do stuff here so
I guess I'm just gonna be guessing
hopefully it'll open one of those
indentations in the walls or maybe it'll
unlock that lock door over there
either way hmm
okay yeah I really got to commend the
guy who spent a lot of time working on
this I mean I'm glad to promote his game
for him because he this is really quite
a well made and I mean it's pretty
original I mean a lot of people try to
do stuff on their own and I commend them
for trying to create something original
okay 561 all right five six two one did
that do something a guns again there was
not much confirmation okay so I can't
click on it again I'm assuming it did
something something I think in here no I
think in here nope one of these doors
unlock maybe nope nope oh hello
whoa hey whoa I have a torch now holy
crap oh it's dark in here
sorry i cants I can't see two feet in
front of my face as torches terrible
okay was this branching eeny meeny miny
left do not like that sound candle oh I
can like that good good okay nice table
setting here listen boxes
climb on roof plate wait why did I pick
up a plate what was the point of that Oh
No
all right let's go left again keep going
left um nope nothing okay get a plate do
I need a do I need to set another table
here is that what I need to do another
candle up yep missing place hang on haha
holy crap what is that bow eyeballs what
the [ __ ] is an ant spider why's that
holy crap ah oh did the door unlock now
Hall oh oh is that the special surprise
yeah the thing was oh wait the bookshelf
is gone say something here
aha
that was hard to see that's really hard
what is that I don't recognize that
noise huh huh what is that I save I can
save I'm not being hunted okay that
wasn't a monster that was just random
noises oh okay
are you okay I'm okay okay okay just
carry on I bet this key does this door
let's see here huh oh great more caverns
love this let's see oh wait there's it
okay whew spiral staircase hello uh go
down I can't go down you're not gonna
let me go down or is that step just too
steep for me yeah whoo where does this
go where am I where are you taking me
where are you taking me okay oh this
looks familiar
oh this is like the UM it's like the
other area hello and got more caverns by
a locked door that I need a key to get
from the other oh hello
whoa what's that what's that whoa where
am I wait what whoa whoa whoa wait whoa
wait did I miss something or wait huh
this looks like slender cost or follow
me up in here what why ah that's a
spider dandy Jesus get out of here holy
crap get out of here get out of here oh
crap it's amazed I'm gonna get trapped
I'm on a diet
gonna die I would say the minute ah oh
god ah I'm thinking of like The Shining
when he's going through the phase right
now
daddy daddy I'm coming for you
daddy daddy did it oh that was it
hot damn I got through that quick ha ha
I got through that rule I got some of
that real quick
Wow ha ha ha thanks for this special I
guessing the aunt was the different
thing because ha ha thing
good god I think with freaky did you
make that like in two seconds of it I'm
not saying like you're so bad quality
but you made it
you updated these versions really
quickly but well done on making that
thing there's legs to flail and
everywhere uh-huh oh alright so anyway
that was awesome I really liked that it
was short but it was still awesome I
kind of I kind of went through it really
quickly because I've been having I've
been trying to get it to work so like I
I kind of got that I got a feel for the
game a lot off-screen but I'm glad that
I was able to get to the end and finish
it up really quickly there so I hope you
guys enjoyed it I want you guys to play
for yourself the link to his website is
in the description below so give it a
look play the game for yourselves thank
you so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
freaky deaky
Wow oh my holy crap why did I blow that
at all so funny man
Oh bro dodge you jeez get higher bunny
man emo